un truc qui cloche
quoi répond qu'est-ce qui est pas normal
à ton avis
on l'aura bien tiré une balle dans la
tête
j'arrive à voir tomber les tirs
on est copains à la dga n'ont gitano du
sud où ils se trouvent
je peux essayer de l'avoir quoi [ __ ]
bien sûr mathieu sergent mathieu sergent
non non non non non des cendres est
imparti sergent matthews est ce que tu
m'entends accroche-toi mais laurent vue
qu'est ce que tu vois et associés
c'est ce qui tire son sérieux il me
reste une balle non non non à la seconde
tu touches ce fusil tu es mort 443 4 5
je sais où tu es maintenant tu as vu y'a
personne j'ai pas où il est il sait
tirer
sauf si c'est un pro ya aucun mouvement
pas une ombre à l'horizon je vais voir
de plus près et c'est tout reçus
le mur en visu et surtout ton cul en
visu ma belle allée vieux rat qu'est ce
que tu vois il y associe c'est qu'avant
c'est grave la balle est ressorti c'est
un homme à terre
[Musique]
proposition terminé on installe peur
mais d'un gros calibre
je demande une extraction vous avez dit
quoi un accent t'es pas des nôtres
tu es un sniper
dis tu es un mec tu leur père et doit s
qui dira sauce est rien si j'étais toi
je commencerai à discuter il a kiss qui
tue je veux apprendre à te connaître
il me reste une balle non non non à la
seconde où tous fusillés morts
c'est vrai quand ce sera fini sa famille
ne le reconnaîtra pas tuer déshydraté
comment ça va finir par cas mort tu vas
te vider de son sang
[Musique]
la lunette est une extension de mon âge
tu publies durable et non je pète la
forme
la t 30 est une extension de mon poids 1
2 3 4 5
le fusil et une extension de moi-même
pendant deux trois quatre cinq ans
peut-être 4,5
je veux qu'un alibi ne sait où tu es
maintenant
[Musique]